Here on our show, we love all things design.
I am a design junkie. I'm a solver.
I believe don't renovate, innovate.
And we also love our environment
and conserving resources
for the next generation. I am a mom with two kids.
I wish I was as awake as I should have been. I am now.
And I'm so excited that we're going to discuss something
that's happening in our world,
that is so on trend for all the right reasons.
Please welcome our next guest.
She's an expert and an entrepreneur.
She is the up-cycling expert
who blew up this year on TikTok,
showing us all how to give second life to everyday items.
Please welcome to the show, Sarah Teresinski!
(audience claps)
Gorgeous!
So nice to meet you guys!
So nice to meet you, too.
So nice to meet you too.
By the way, what does up-cycling mean to you?
How should we be thinking about that term?
Well I think, up-cycling, for me
it started out of a necessity
because many moons ago I was a single mom,
and I wanted to have things for my baby girl
that she could wear.
So I started taking my old t-shirts and making her dresses,
and then I would go thrifting
and I would want to design a room
'cause I couldn't afford anything else.
So for me, at first, it was necessity,
and then it became about, you know,
I ended up getting married and having more kids
and I'm like, I have this whole little crew of people
and I really need to keep this moving for them.
And now it's about so much more than a necessity,
but I understand what it's like to need it as a necessity,
but there's so much amazing stuff already out there
and we should be using it, right?
I love that -
Reworking it, having fun with it.
you gave a second life to items,
but that you yourself had a second life as well.
I know, for real.
Can I just ask real quick?
What are we going to up-cycle today?
'Cause I have a glue gun and I need to use it.
Okay.
So can we please, I'm being patient. I wanna craft!
He's ready.
Please
All right, bring us home Ross.
Thank you.
Okay. Ross and Drew, we have two up-cycles today.
We're going to start with number one and they kind of fold
into each other. We're going to start with our cans.
Don't use a standard soup can, just a little bit bigger
like those tomato size cans.
Oh, that's what these are, yeah okay.
Take the top and bottom off.
So then you take your wallpaper and you guys just grab your
pieces of wallpaper. You peel it off.
Cause Drew has the easiest peel and stick wallpaper
Thank you. I appreciate that.
Oh my god, it is easy. Look at that. That was so easy.
Oh, my gosh.
Then you just bring your paper around,
right, you kind of center it and if you,
if you mess up the corners, it's no big deal.
You can just come through with an X-Acto knife.
Mrs. T, Mrs. T, Mrs. T, look, I did it.
You did it. Then what you do,
so we already have a couple that are already done
for sake of TV. So you guys have these.
So what you want to do,
take your glue gun
Uh huh.
And just line the two edges right here.
Oh.
Just have fun with it.
And my motto is it never has to be perfect.
You don't have to make it perfect. Just have fun with it.
It doesn't have to be, but mine is.
Have fun with it.
Nobody notices. Okay.
So then you turn this this way and Drew,
you want to put some lines here.
Oh, happily.
Yes. And then you just jam that sucker down
on there and it's hot glue, so look!
I know. I did it, I know I'm doing it.
And then you, you hold them in place
just a few minutes watching your fingers.
And then as soon as they dry,
usually give about five minutes, then you guys,
you can slide your bottles in.
This is so cute, can you picture this?
Like on a bar cart, you guys.
Well Ross, you, I just redid Ross's dressing room,
and surprised him with it.
It's so pretty you guys.
I'm so glad. Cause I, I wanted so bad to make you happy,
but he wanted a little bar cart.
So when we realized we were doing the segment with you,
somebody got real excited.
So can we, can you help me make a bar cart,
but I want to up-cycle it.
Okay, well you are up-cycling it
because it's a diaper changing table.
And so just, we allotted the nursery into your kitchen
and, and repaint it. We want it.
I had the wrong changing table.
Yeah, well these are so great.
And these are all over secondhand. You guys,
you just cut your paper and you cover.
If you peel it off here and then Drew,
you just match it up in the corner. Again,
it doesn't have to be perfect.
You can always come through and then just slide that down.
You can always come through with your X-Acto knife
and cut those corners. Ross, you're doing great.
Yeah Mrs. T this is a little harder than the can.
I just want to say.
It's really, I promise you're going to
have it loaded with stuff.
So even if there's a little bubble in it just come through
and spread it out, right.
Okay.
Just like that, get your corners.
Okay, so this was in a thrift store
and now it looks like this?
Yes.
Sold. Thank you so much.
Yeah, little babies on it.
That's so cute!
Isn't that so fun? Then you can take your wine rack
and you can put it on there.
And then Ross is like,
Oh I'm so into this
Oh my gosh, he's ready to like entertain.
Your thing looks way better than mine, Rossy.
Well, I wasn't going to bring it up,
but now that you mentioned it. Yeah.
I know. But the good news is the bar cart's
for your room, not mine.
And you know what Drew,
you can actually set it the other way as well.
You could put your napkins in there.
You know what, I can.
Oh, pun intended
There's no way
I love that, look at that.
Exactly. Right?
That's the whole point about up-cycling
and crafting Drew, see she just made her own
That's what I meant to do, Rossy.
You made yours your own. And they look great.
This is so much fun and I cannot believe how easy it was.
So easy. And very fun.
Perfect.
I mean, look at that cart. That's like
the finished product.
That looks amazing.
That's the goal.
That is goals, right there. So fun.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, Mrs. T. Thank you Rossy.
Thank you Drew.
That's going right upstairs. Oh I think we'll take
that one upstairs.
Yeah, I want the one that she did. Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, you do.
(upbeat music)